[Music]
now when I sat down with their celebrity
neighbor Kathy Griffin the most alarming
headline in Kim's life at that time was
the robbery in Paris so you've seen her
since the whole really next weekend
and how's she doing she's doing fine
Kathy gave us a quick update on Kim who
says she has a super quiet and
respectful neighbor but even after the
traumatic robbery in Paris Kim's still
not immune to the stand up comics
irreverent brand of humour anxious
excited emotional three words to
describe what I'm feeling right now
which is three more than I thought you
knew
the last thing Kim Kardashian actually
said to me was cuz I warned her I said
just you know we might get along you're
never out of the act and she's just like
I get it it's an honor and I was like
good girl good girl Kim said this to you
yeah I think she was counting her money
while she said it so she was distracted
her in-your-face attitude has earned
Kathy allegiance of fans and a reported
20 million dollar net worth
now she's dishing it out in her new book
Kathy Griffin's celebrity run-ins i sat
down with her at mama shelter Hotel in
LA where she told me about the time she
called out Leonardo DiCaprio I was
presenting at the Directors Guild of
America but Leo made the mistake of just
scrolling on the Twitter I was it and
basically I lovingly tortured Leonardo
DiCaprio I believe I called him a
man-whore from the stage he leaned in
and he goes like this oh and I that's
why I felt one of them but sometimes you
gotta me slippery's got to be a little
bit of afraid of course last time I went
to a Grammy party and I looked at Taylor
Swift across the room and I really was
trying to make her laugh congratulations
I'm excited to see it
tonight I look at swifty thinking she's
gonna giggle and I go hey and she Lynch
it feels like other stars in the griffon
hitless Ashton Kutcher who she says
refused to talk to her during a charity
performance they did to get it can't
imagine why
so Ashton Kutcher released some kind of
statements saying that um marriage is
one of the most difficult things in the
world really I would say fighting cancer
I just assumed he'd be like a nice guy
and stuff it was very bizarre and
there's Miley Cyrus who she's actually
made peace with we worked the whole day
together and she turns to me and she
goes so this whole time you just be like
kidding and I go yeah this whole time
babe it's really really just all in fun
I've never ruined anyone's career I've
never been a cause of a loss of income
like I think by the way I made fun of
Oprah a lot I think she's okay I don't
think she's bankrupt for now
you